nach diesem video habe ich all meine
noch vorhandenen gehirnzellen verloren
hat und mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir hat mal wieder auf youtube
unterwegs und hat mir dort die trends zu
gemüte geführt
wir haben da videos sollen wie
beispielsweise von da so eine
zusammenfassung von liverpool gegen
mancity dann haben wir ein neues lied
von data love the cronk drin wir haben
einen hollywood film und unter anderem
auch auf platz nummer eins in den trends
diamond as you der ja lange zeit
irgendwie verschollen war ich habe vor
einiger zeit bereits auf ein video von
seinen reagiert wo er einen geist in
seiner wohnung entdeckt hat alles klaus
heimann an der stelle noch mal von mir
hier mein aufrichtiges beileid dass du
in so einer wohnung leben muss aber ich
würde sagen wir schauen uns erst mal
ganz kurz daheim ins kanal an die
letzten videos hier von ihm sind nie so
krass gut angekommen wie die die er
damals gemacht hat also ich glaube wir
können uns alle an die zeit erinnern
wohl der schnell wachsende deutsche
youtube kanal war zu dieser mit diesem
ganzen musical videos da ja dreieinhalb
millionen abonnenten auf youtube und da
sind natürlich so 300.000 280.000 180000
260.000 114000 sind nicht so krasse
klicks wie die die er früher gemacht hat
doch jetzt ist anscheinend etwas ins
heim ins leben vorgefallen was das ganze
wieder ändern könnte und das ist sein
neues auto hat hier vor drei tagen ein
video hochgeladen was mal wieder auf die
halbe million klicks zu geht wo endlich
im titel steht und er einen lamborghini
auf dem terminal hat das video hat satte
24.000 likes und 28.000 discs also schon
relativ gut bewertet wie viele videos
willst du noch mit einem lama als ampel
raushauen unlustig to do list adblock
aktivieren video wegen ihrer führenden
inhalt melden diesen kommentar schreiben
und so was in den trends alter bist du
unlustig du bist und bleibst egal was du
machen willst ein hu so das waren jetzt
nur einige der 20.000 kommentare die
unter das video geschrieben wurden aber
da gibt es schon noch deutlich härtere
allerdings meine damen und herren wir
gehen aber wieder komplett
unvoreingenommen rhein an der stelle
auch noch mal der typische disclaimer
wenn ich auf videos von anderen youtube
an reagiere nicht dass da wieder
irgendwelche nicht dass das wieder
irgendwie falsch verstehen ich habe
nichts persönlich gegen sam mendes tue
ich habe mich noch nie wirklich mit ihm
unterhalten
gt lediglich um seine letzten beiden
hochgeladenen videos und darauf reagiere
ich jetzt mal ist bei mir auch mal so
ich springe irgendwohin verleben schulen
dritten explosion auf die und bevor ihr
das video seht hier ist mal ein paar
dazu gutscheine für die ersten früchte
er hat
er verschenkt amazon gutscheine ein paar
sekunden später wjb also wir kriegen
jetzt einfach mal ihrem konto
gutschreiben
o
das heim in ganze nicht auch einschenken
also wenn ihr noch nicht auf instagram
folgt vor allem jetzt wo instagram
kommen und alter krass folgt dem safer
auf instagram ich vergesse die
notification machen ja jetzt geht es
wieder um schmuck sieht sie zieht er
seiner freude über den schuh an
da ist ein lambo freunde ein viertel des
videos ist bisher nur das intro er sagt
dass der amazon gutschein ersten
verlosen dass man ihm auf instagram
folgen soll und so weiter und so fort
also ich bin jetzt mal vor zu der stelle
wo er und sein auto zeigt müssen sie
aber noch nicht
jetzt geht's ab 3
das heißt ein vw polo
vielleicht ist es ein job und er zeigt
am ende noch noch sein lambo und dann
wäre es ja auch kein video mit
irreführenden inhalt heißt es gibt mir
jetzt mal so ein bisschen durch das
video durch er zeigt jetzt irgend so ein
vw polo der glaube ich nicht seiner ist
es gibt mal müssen ans ende vielleicht
sagt er jetzt dass sie jetzt jetzt zeigt
er denke ich mal sein neues auto aber
das nicht zeigen warum machst du dann
einen lamborghini aventador oft ein
thumbnail
das macht keinen sinn es ist kein vw
polo was kann das sein auf jeden fall
kleiner tipp es macht so weiß jeder
welches auto gemeint ist nissan almera
tino wenn du in den nissan almera tino
sonst hätte es noch von unter den ausbau
freien braucht man halt er sich nämlich
genau so an wie es sein dass hier
beschreibt man also schaut euch einfach
mal diese eine szene an
[Musik]
bin ich hier gelandet
es ist ein kleines rätsel video welches
wieder ich mir gekauft am sonntag kommt
das neue video liefert
was
du hast auf dem van delden auto gezeigt
wo ist das ein rätsel video er packt of
sale einen lamborghini aventador um dann
im video zu fragen welches auto habe ich
mir gekauft
und warum steht in den trends ferrari
488 ich haben im nachhinein jetzt mal
die tags von dem video angeschaut und
zwar lamborghini und lamborghini
aventador ist nicht im video fahren
sondern nur auf den ferrari ist
nirgendwo vorhandenen super cars ist nur
einzupacken und der dass es auf dem
terminal ferrari 488 wieder nicht
vorhanden traumautos auch nicht
vorhanden green car garage das ist ein
ganz normales parkhaus der neue
lamborghini reventon mit kein mal
erwähnt und der lamborghini hurra kann
das auch nirgendwo vorhanden also die
tags da macht keiner irgendwie von sinn
allerdings war das video von salmon
anscheinend nur eine rätsel video wo
seine community oder dem video raten
konnte ok hat er sich das auto geholt
oder dass ich meinen der der das
thumbnail gesehen hat und das ist sicher
jeder der weiß es eh schon aber aber
aber wir wollen nicht nur darauf
reagieren sondern auch auf seinen neuen
veröffentlichten tracks no money und da
steht er wirklich vor einem lambo wir
lassen jetzt nach außen fordert er in
seinem rätsel video einen orangenen
lamborghini aventador auf dem tempel
hatte und jetzt auf diesem video von
einem blauen huracan steht so das macht
wieder vorn und hinten keinen sinn ich
habe diesen formen in ca 20 minuten
geschrieben und aufgenommen plus das
musikvideo gedreht und schnitt noch mal
ca 2 stunden alles in allem zwei stunden
und 20 minuten für dieses unfassbar
coole video also er sagt direkt in der
beschreibung des videos dass er echt
nicht viel zeit in dieses video
reingesteckt hat das heißt er warnt uns
schon mal vor und zeigt uns leute
erwartet nicht zu viel wir haben da echt
wenig zeit reingesteckt das ist
natürlich nicht weil auf der einen seite
kann man dann nicht hätten wenn es
wirklich scheiße ist und auf der anderen
seite wenn es richtig geil ist kann man
immer noch sagen wo und das hat er in
zwei stunden und 20 minuten hingekriegt
also seinen guter schachzug schauen uns
vorher auch noch mal wieder kurz die
bewertungen an und zwar 56.000 daumen
hoch und 73.000 daumen runter
das ist auch wieder richtig gut
ja auch mein gott moment moment moment
ist das young movement gang jetzt weiß
ich auch mal endlich wofür dieses miami
immer steht die junge bewegungs gang
ich wusste echt ich wofür dieses thema
steht aber anscheinend ist dass die
tassen merchandise sein
das ist einfach ein gepflegtes
lamborghini logo in der tat aber gut
meine damen und herren wir hören uns
sofort den sorgen anschauen uns jedoch
vorher noch so 56 kommentare unter dem
video an ich gehe dann mal wieder die
höheren nach diesem video habe ich all
meine noch vorhandenen gehirnzellen
verloren 3 geschützen bitte ich werde
nie so dumm gott keine qualität und du
hast schreibfehler im lied ohren krebs
wir hören einfach mal rein also ich habe
diesen song
steht zwei stunden 20
[Musik]
das ist erstmal grundsätzlich gelogen
wenn man sich einmal die youtube-seite
mir das hier anguckt sehen wir dass er
insgesamt 540 millionen video views hat
das sind so umgerechnet es gibt ja diese
öffentlich bekannten statistiken dass
man pro 1000 klicks ein euro verdient
das heißt er hat so ungefähr eine halbe
millionen schon durch youtube verdient
und das ist auf jeden fall nicht no
money nicht erinnert der frühe und alles
hier mit diesem ganzen ich hab noch
money no money no money no money no
money no money money so ein bisschen ein
gucci gucci gucci gucci gucci
überfällige rechnung und ein viertel mit
also ich verstehe das ganze komplett
einfach gar nicht es gibt derzeit diesen
trend sag ich mal in amerika das jd
power laufen poldi alle irgendwie die
ganze zeit songs herausbringen weiß
songs unmengen an klicks machen ich weiß
nicht ob es einen damit ziehen will er
hat ja auch in der zeit wo jack poole
übels gehalt wurde auch plötzlich dann
diese ganzen daily blogs gemacht über
uns so also ich weiß nicht was seine
intention ist hat im ganzen
gesamtkonstrukt dieses videos ist
allerdings ja also ich verstehe den text
irgendwie nicht so ganz was er damit
sagen will er sagt er hat kein geld
erfährt kein amg aber wahrscheinlich
zeigt er am ende noch sein lambo ich
würde sagen jetzt gibt mich jetzt
einfach auf so ein bisschen durch also
wir sehen indirekt so das ist alles er
nimmt sich ein bisschen selbst auf die
schippe das mag ich eigentlich ganz gern
und dass er sagt norma nie und wenn
jetzt daher zeigen würde haye ich habe
mir hier diesen pinken vw polo wirklich
gekauft und werde ihn jetzt auf türen
und fenster geile lustige aktionen
allerdings haben auf dem teil ja schon
den lamborghini gesehen das heißt wir
blicken jetzt einfach mal auf clay
es ist nur account
es ist ein schönes auto muss man sagen
nennt man ihn und man also er will mit
dem video klar machen dass er sich
keinen bmw und alles mögliche geholt hat
und er halt kein geld hat aber er hat
kein geld weil er sich auf den lambo
geholt hat
also wir können zusammenfassend sagen
samen des ju hat in seinem vorletzten
video gesagt endlich ich habe mir hier
neues auto gekauft man klickt drauf es
sind vielmehr discs als likes weil in
dem video nur sagt dass er sein neues
auto demnächst erst vorstellen wird dann
liegt ein paar tage später das lied no
money hoch indem er sagt dass er die
ganze zeit kein geld hatte um dann am
ende ein auto zu zeigen was 170000 euro
kostet und dann blendet er am ende des
liedes sogar noch ein to be continued
also kommt wahrscheinlich demnächst das
dritte video in folge mit seinem
lamborghini ich mein ich finde youtuber
sollten sich kaufen was sie möchten sie
haben das geld ja selbst verdient und
das kann man natürlich für sachen
ausgeben wie man möchte meine
leidenschaft für autos hat dann sondern
sich autos holen wenn man wohnungen mag
kann man sich eine wohnung kaufen wenn
man uhrenmarkt wenn man klamotten mag
wenn man schminken mag wenn man was weiß
ich was mag das kann man ja für alles
selbst ausgeben
aber ich finde wenn man damit so krass
prallt dann ist es also erlebt drei
videos zwei videos wahrscheinlich kommt
bald das dritte nur von seinem
lamborghini huracan hoch wenn er die
karre haben würde und mit der
herumfahren würde und so ist es ja
komplett sein ding aber er drückt es den
leuten so unter die nase und es mich so
ein bisschen ekelhaft das weiß ich von
video meine damen und herren zahlen
falls du das hier sehen solltest das ist
überhaupt nicht gegen dich ich wollte
einfach nur darauf reagieren weil mir
das hälfte leute geschrieben haben und
das video jetzt auch schon seit drei
tagen trends platz eins ist ich wollte
in einem der nächsten videos von mir auf
cape reagiere das ist irgendwie so eine
asiatische musik genre musikrichtung
keine ahnung was also wenn ihr dazu
irgendwelche links hat schreiben die
gern mal die kommentare und auch
youtuber auf die ich eventuell auch noch
einmal reagieren soll also die jetzt
irgendwie weil sie nicht auch irgendwie
scheiße gemacht habe in letzter zeit
etwas hochgeladen haben keine ahnung was
los